everybody I'm Walter Bernays yak and
this is top five here we countdown the
best and worst performances of our most
beloved actors today we take a look at
the worst a fire marshal bill himself
Jim Carrey as stated in last week's
episode Jim Carrey is a really good
actor with a lot of range when people
say they don't like him it's usually
because they find his overly exaggerated
comedic stylings off-putting that's the
thing about comedy though it's very
subjective even more so than dramas what
one person may find funny another may
not it's for that reason that this list
is less Wurst and more least best carry
always gives 100% in all these roles but
these are the ones that didn't quite at
the mark number 5 charlie baileygates /
Hank Evans in me myself and Irene the
Farley Brothers have a shoddy track
record their films range from pretty
funny to gross Carrie isn't awful in
this but I think it's one of his weaker
comedic performances meet charlie
baileygates a 17-year veteran of the
Rhode Island police ports charlie is
mild mannered hard-working always
helpful and a devoted and loving father
to three sons
unfortunately Charlie has split
personality disorder and when he runs
out of his medication meet Hank
Charlie's hyper aggressive alter ego
Hank's got a filthy mouth drinks like a
fish breaks skulls and is quite the
perfect
carry once again plays dual roles on
this while charlie is the straight man
everyone walks all over his comedy kind
of falls flat hank is his repressed side
well a lot of the jokes rely on but
carries deeper voice and darker demeanor
don't do much to make the movie funnier
I will give Kerry credit for fully
committing to both roles here there are
points when he plays both at the same
time the back and forth he has with
himself is at least impressive to watch
still it's one of his least notable
performances and slides in at number
five number four the Cable Guy in the
Cable Guy this movie has a really bad
reputation but honestly it's not as bad
as most people say Ben Stiller directed
this 1996
dark comedy and Jim Carrey got the
biggest payday of any actor up to this
point well this is another example of
Kerry giving it as all this role just
comes up short
oddball cable installer chip Douglas
attempts to strike up a friendship with
customer Stephen Kovacs by offering him
premium channels at no cost while
Stephen rebuffs chips frequent need for
companionship chip goes from a mildly
eccentric acquaintance to a full-fledged
psycho stalker though it's increasingly
apparent to Stephen that the Cable Guy
is dangerous convincing his friends
family and authorities of that is
another matter entirely
Kerry gives the Cable Guy a lisp that
can grate on you after a while
he goes all out with this over-the-top
performance and while there are a couple
scenes where this character works pretty
well most of the movie he comes off as
more annoying than entertaining while
Kerry doesn't dazzle on this the worst
performance in this movie is without a
doubt Matthew Broderick plus his
character is way too unlikable to lead
the film he doesn't give Kerry a good
character to bounce off of maybe if
there was someone different in that role
the Cable Guy would have come off a
little better the ending message of this
film is very similar in some respects to
the Truman Show if you want to learn the
lesson that this movie is preaching just
go watch that this concludes our
broadcast day number 3
Walter Sparrow / fingerling in the
number 23 while this is a fantastic name
for a lead character Walter Sparrow
leaves a lot to be desired and
fingerling is a bit worse a man's
discovery of an obscure book about the
number 23 leads him on a descent into
darkness as he becomes more obsessed
with its contents he becomes more
convinced that it is in fact based on
his life his horror he discovers grave
consequences in store for the book's
main character here is an example of
Kerry doing a serious role in this case
- that just doesn't work the Walter
Sparrow character slowly descends into
madness throughout the film Kerry
doesn't exactly excel in those scenes of
course we know he's capable of playing
great serious characters but the
combination of bad direction and overly
convoluted plot and ineffective editing
don't do him any favors what's worse is
the fingerling character most of his
lines
narration and it really comes off like a
comedic bit Carrie would play just
listen to this this detective was born
detective fingerling suicide bond tells
me she was a good person once but now
I'm a bad person but somebody had used
all the coffee our detective a serious
detective seriously serious and all the
ways that a serious
do you like my coat I got it at JCPenny
they love your style if this concept was
taken a different way the number 23
could have been a really smart clever
and cool movie but as is it's pretty
lame just skip it number 2 Count Olaf
and Lemony Snicket's A Series of
Unfortunate Events this is where it gets
kind of bad I can't say that it's lazy
but Carrey could have tweaked a few
things that make Count Olaf more
interesting after the three young
Baudelaire siblings are left orphaned by
a fire in a mansion they are carted off
to live with their distant relative
Count Olaf unfortunately all off is a
cruel scheming man only after the
inheritance that the eldest Baudelaire
violet is set to receive the children
escape and find shelter with their
quirky uncle Monte and subsequently
their phobic and Josephine but Olaf is
never far behind based on the book
series this movie plays out more like a
discount Tim Burton movie the costumes
the tone the sets they all just smell
Burton E hopefully the upcoming Netflix
series will be more interesting from the
beginning I saw something was off with
Carey's performance it's obvious he was
trying very hard to create a
larger-than-life character however the
effort is wasted instead of disappearing
into this role like he did with Andy
Kaufman Carrey still exudes a few Carrie
isms that remind you it's him under
there the whole time
[Music]
in a small part of the movie he dresses
in disguise as Stefano and that is
legitimately funny it's too bad he
couldn't have just played that role for
the whole movie he tried and did not
succeed in making all off a great
character but it's still better than his
worst performance and the number one
worst Jim Carrey performance is mr. Dean
nygma Edward nygma
but you can call me the Riddler
mr. Schumacher welcome to your second
spot on this list yes it seems like the
combo of Carrie and Schumacher never
really works well this is pretty much
Carrie at his most popular and it seems
like he was not only given free rein but
encouraged to go as over-the-top as
possible the results much like this
movie aren't great Batman faces off
against two foes the schizophrenic
horribly scarred former District
Attorney Harvey Dent aka two-face and
the Riddler a disgruntled ex Wayne
Enterprises inventor seeking revenge
against his former employer by
unleashing his brain-sucking weapon on
Gotham City's residents as the Caped
Crusader also deals with tortured
memories of his parents murder
he has a new romance with psychologist
chase Marini
tell me doctor do you like the circus
Circus Circus Circus let me get this out
of the way first it was really weird
going back to watch Batman Forever say
what you will about my pal Zack but at
least he takes the material seriously
I'm cold almost everything about this
movie is just ridiculous it's not
worthless though there is some good
stuff here with the story of Dick
Grayson becoming Robin and even a few
elements of Bruce Wayne's arc but the
majority is annoying and too loud to
ignore Carrie is a big part of that
obnoxiousness his Edward nygma and
Riddler portrayal is at a 10 the entire
time there's no break from his craziness
when I said people find him to be too
much this is the perfect performance to
point towards Tommy Lee Jones as
two-face is just as bad if not worse so
a lot of the blame can be laid on
Schumacher but Kerry took this to a
whole nother level
Cathi kill yeah how's my mole was that
over-the-top I can never tell sidenote
best part of this movie seals kissing
the rose the Riddler is a great
character who deserves better hopefully
down the road will get a serious
interpretation of him so in my opinion
that's his worst however the good far
outweigh the bad for Jim Carrey if you
haven't go back and check out my top 5
best Jim Carrey performances video I
want to hear what you guys think what is
your least favorite Jim Carrey movie and
performance who do you want me to cover
next in the show leave a comment and let
me know follow me on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter and come back right
here next week for a new top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you